this year the Academy in order to
express its appreciation to one of its
members for a unique screen career has
voted an Oscar to mr. Cary Grant for
sheer brilliance and the acting business
no one's brought more pleasure to more
people for as many years as Kerry has
and no one has done more things well for
light comedy too strong drama and made
it look easier no one has been more
admired and loved by his fellow actors
for skill for finesse for subtlety charm
and for being Cary Grant now to give you
an idea of how I personally feel about
Cary I like to say that if Cary Grant
has starred in this particular film
called the kissing bandit it would have
been the biggest hit of all times
you're applauding my stamina you realize
that I'm the only girl you ever work
with an ever slapped you you must be
tired after all that action up their
butt while they've got a little energy
left you better take this now I think I
want to take it not your you fall down
that's it thank you can I ask you
something
sure what did you do to deserve all that
rough stuff and all that slapping up
there
I don't remember on this thing are you
sure yes I'm sure sure you weren't
fooling around a little bit before this
year that I'd remember how about those
love scenes that you were doing in there
with all those pretty gals unless oh
well those I wouldn't mind me taking you
really wouldn't hey you think you can
handle it I could try are you sure
no topical jokes I thought you might
want to join the club that's all
I'm I'm very grateful to be here
Academy's board of directors for this
happy tribute and to Frank for coming
here especially to give it to me and to
all the fellows who worked so hard and
finding those and assembling those film
tips you know I may never look at this
without remembering the quiet patience
of the directors who was so kind to me
were kind enough to put up with me more
than once someone living in three or
four times it was Howard Hawks Hitchcock
legally Meharry George Stevens George
kyouko and Stanley Donen and all the
writers it was Philip Barry
Dorrie sherry Bob Sherman Ben Hecht
dear Clifford Odets Sidney Sheldon and
more recently Stanley Shapiro and Peter
stone well I trust they and all the
other directors writers and producers
and leading women have all forgiven me
what I didn't know I realize is
conventional and usual to praise one's
fellow workers on these occasions but
why not ours is a collaborative medium
we all need each other that's how
and what better opportunity is there to
publicly express one's appreciation and
admiration and affection for all those
who contribute to so much to each of our
welfare I you know I've never been a
joiner or member of any particular
social set but I've been privileged to
be a part of Hollywood's most glorious
era and yet tonight thinking of all the
empty screens that are waiting to be
filled and marvelous images and
ideologies points of view whatever and
considering all the students who are
studying film techniques in the
universities throughout the world and
the astonishing young talents that are
coming up in our midst I think there's
an even more glorious era right around
the corner so before I leave you I want
to thank you very much for signifying
your approval of this I should cherish
it until I die because probably no
greater honor can come to any man than
the respect of his colleagues thank you
you